everybody I'm Chris Pine I am very  excited for y'all to see jack ryan  shadow recruit at your local IMAX  theater and joy now talk me through your  very scary scenario climax experiences  are always I find incredibly memorable  so we try to kill me it is you know  fantastically immersive it's so steep  and the screen is so huge Jack work okay  our style was to try and put the  audience where Jack is and where Jack is  is pretty suspenseful the hell is going  on here once aware of the very very  different nature of it especially in a  world where many people see things on  much smaller devices the act of going  and seeing something in imax is you're  really forgiving yourself to a unique  kind of experience  you